hello everyone i'm peter kish a second
year phd student at the university of
work and i'll be presenting my paper
titled deterministic dynamic matching in
worst case update time and i would like
to say special thanks to my phd
supervisor sharing bhattacharya and
touchable cernerock for helpful
conversations and hints regarding this
project
we will be focusing on the matching
problem
where our goal is to find a large
disjoint a large set of vertex disjoint
edges and for clarity we will refer to
the maximum matching size of g as mu of
g as standard in literature and we will
say that the matching m is alpha
approximate if it holds that its size is
at least one over alpha times the size
of a maximum matching
we will be considering the dynamic
setting where our goal is not just
simply to compute an output for a given
input but we assume that the input
undergoes updates over time and our goal
is to maintain an output
during these updates
in the case of the imaging problem we
usually consider edge insertions and
deletions as updates
we want and for any dynamic problem we
could always just re-run our favorite
static algorithm for the problem after
each update but we want to do way faster
than this
when it comes to
so the goal in the dynamic setting is
naturally to minimize the time it takes
to complete an update to complete
to calculate the appropriate output
after an update
however the way we measure this update
time
can be
different
um so the intuitive way of measuring
wait times is simply considering the
maximum time the algorithm might take to
calculate an update but in the case of
some problems and some approximation
ratios for the matching problem in
particular
are
that uh worst case update time bans
uh
are hard to be found so we consider
instead amortizing the update time over
a series of updates and we just derive a
running an update time band over some
banded series of updates
clear worst case update time band is
superior to an advertised update time
bound in this sense
and it is ideal to aim for worst case
update time algorithms as they would
yield more reliable algorithms in
practice
the dynamic matching problem has been
extensively studied this is just a small
survey of results
uh state-of-the-art results in the and
for the particular approximation ratios
we will be considering here
um
[Music]
and we will be deriving a few new uh
results with specific approximation
ratios in the worst uh with worst case
update time bounds
through
through showing a general framework for
improving specific kind of uh
amortized update time band dynamic
algorithms
uh i call amortized rebuild based
algorithms to worst case update time the
three new results we are deriving are
two plus epsilon approximation in
polylog update time
uh
uh three half plus epsilon approximation
in root and times polylog update time
which is randomized against adaptive
adversaries on what that means more
later
and
a deterministic algorithm
for the same approximation ratio with a
slight overhead of n to the little of
one compared to the competitors
randomized
implementation
so what are amortized rebuild-based
dynamic algorithms
quite a lot of algorithms specific in
the matching problem
rely on the robustness of the output or
the data structure they are maintaining
and the way to imagine that
can be the same through a simple example
assume we assume we
find a matching in a graph
one plus epsilon approximate matching a
graph with our favorite matching
algorithm
this can be done in semi-linear time
using four claw logarithms
if we were to just simply wait for a
number of updates
the matching we initially found would
still actually be fairly good
approximation if we would wait for a
number of updates proportional to the
matching size in the graph and at this
point
we could recalculate the whole matching
and amortize the number of updates or
where it is uh over
amortize the cost of the static
algorithm over these number of updates
and this would not give us anything
non-trivial in terms of worst case
update time but could give us very nice
amortized update time bands
and the goal of this paper is to show
how to transform these kind of
algorithms to one which actually has
very nice or escaped update time bounds
right so to do this we will uh introduce
a um
a different definition on update time
which was first noted the uh the first
observed by the important touch of all
2016.
essentially what we are looking for here
is a slightly stronger condition than
just simply an amortized update time
band so instead
what we do is don't not amortize the
running time or the update time over the
whole series of outputs or an arbitrary
subsequence of outputs but the algorithm
can specifically
define over which subsequences
it is amortizing the update time over so
what i mean by that
is that the algorithm so for a given
input sequence the algorithm can specify
that
the
what subsequences will the update time
will be what subsequences will the
update time be amortized over
um
if it can do it over k subsequences we
call it k batch dynamic uh for
simplicity
and clearly this is a stronger property
than an amortized update time bound well
in a weaker property than a worst case
update time band essentially an
amortized update time algorithm is a one
batch dynamic algorithm so to say
right
so this was observed in the very same
paper but not explicitly stated
that if we can select k to be poly log n
in magnitude
then we can design an algorithm
which
has several output tapes and maintain
several outputs
such that at any time during the updates
at least one of these output tapes
contains the correct result
however
even though it has more output tapes
it now has worst case update time which
is just a polylock factor larger
than the underlying algorithms update
time and in case of the matching problem
this is very nice because
an output of a matching algorithm is a
matching
yeah it's obviously a matching
which is just a graph with maximum
degree one therefore the union of a
small number of such outputs is a very
small graph with very small maximum
degree and in these graphs these kind of
graphs there are already
algorithms for finding a very
an almost perfect matching
so essentially
we can in parallel
uh maintain an output over all of these
tapes in the case of the matching
problem
um very briefly on how one should
imagine this kind of transformation uh
i'm not going to expand on this in
detail because uh it's not the result of
this paper
essentially we just simulate the
underlying algorithm on the number of
output tapes while making sure that on
at least one of the output tapes the
very last input element at any time is a
complete
batch of one of the sub algorithms
running on those tapes and when a tape
is not
containing the correct solution it is
reversing
uh some of its batches so it doesn't run
out of batches to use
essentially the tapes are moving back
and forth in time more on this indeed on
the paper and in the original 2016 paper
which introduces this concept
now
how would okay so the
idea is that an amortized rebuild-based
dynamic algorithm can easily be turned
into a k-patch dynamic algorithm this is
a core observation here
and had to imagine that
let's just go back
to the matching example we similarly do
the same thing as before we complete the
one plus epsilon approximate matching in
semi-linear time
as we did before and we want to make it
now cape edge dynamic so what we do
is that we complete the rebuilds
by a k factor more often
and
whenever a new batch begins we delay by
the first rebuild by
some factor
and what this ensures is that small
subsequences the algorithm might choose
as a batch
will not contain a rebuild
and this way it guarantees that
there will be sort of enough elements in
every subsequence to amortize
the update time if the update time is
long due to a rebuild the idea simple as
that
so this kind of
this observation leads to a four-step
design for worst-case step update type
worst case update time algorithm
first off we need an amortized rebuild
based algorithm we improve it to batch
dynamic through the simple trick which
is more
more detailed in the paper
uh and we used uh
existing works
in literature to improve it to
worst case update time and
we solve the problem on the union of the
tapes because that is just easier to
handle at the end
and
this framework instantly will yield us
two results one of them
is simpler than the other
since for two plus epsilon approximation
there has already been an amortized
rebuild
based
algorithm and
to get to make it worst cases we just
straightforward apply the framework
described in the paper that's easy as
that now we also receive a band for
three over two plus epsilon
approximation however algorithms for
this problem were not as far as i'm
aware amortized rebuild based
so
we will need a new algorithm
and once we have such an algorithm we
can just apply the framework in a black
box manner
so
as
the core phenomena rebuild based
algorithm is a
is a very robust data structure which
can withstand the number of updates
while maintaining its uh
output guarantee
and just to give an example
the just to take the matching examples
previously
as a matching is essentially a small
number of edges it is not very robust
against updates
so the appropriate data structure for
our purposes will be an edge degree
constraints subgraph which was
introduced uh in a very influential
paper by residence then in 2015 and if
parameters are chosen well
it can withstand
uh mu of g times root of n updates while
still preser uh will still
maintaining a good approximation ratio
assuming the matching size is large
but
and
let's just assume that we can find such
an edcs i as it is not the result of
this paper and it's fairly technical i'm
not going into
what such a subgraph is specifically
then if we would be able to find this in
semi-linear time and it can withstand uh
about mu of g times root of n updates if
mu of g is comparable to the size of the
graph
then we would instantaneously have
a
root of n
or
a bad root of an update time uh
amortized rebuilt based algorithm but
there are two ifs involved in this
statement so the two difficulties is
that before this paper i'm not aware of
the existence of a
semi-linear static algorithm for finding
an edcs for the parameters of our
choosing
and
it could also occur that the graph
doesn't happen to have a
large matching inside of it and also
requires consideration
so
one of the results presented in the
paper is
finding such a semi-linear up
running time static algorithm for
finding
such an edcs
and on a high level this algorithm
is just
parallelizing
the standard algorithms for finding a
edcs
so normally ddcs's are found by
putting about
images in and out of an x that we are
continuously building however the time
it takes for us to find these edges
makes it so that we can't uh or at least
we don't know how to make this in linear
time
instead what we do is that
we kind of weaken the definition of an
edcs and we allow it to be locally
faulty
and this way we can
complete the same process through just a
small number of passes through the edge
sets
and it will be working on the majority
of the graph
because it is only faulty on a small
part of the graph if the matching size
of the graph is fairly large we can
disregard that small section as a slack
parameter
so
the slightly weaker data structure we
introduce only works again if the
matching size is large which we will
need for two different reasons now but
it does yield us a semi-linear time
algorithm
and aesthetics i think which is
not true for a normal edcs
now how are we going to guarantee that
the matching size of the in the graph is
fairly large well there's a very
standard attitude
or approach
uh
to guarantee this for us which appeared
in a number of works but i think first
in a saudi 2019
the idea is simply
to contract the vertex set in such a way
that we preserve a large portion of a
maximum matching so we guarantee that
it's in contracted at vertex that we can
still find the maximum matching
on a very high level
let's just assume that the graph has
some nodes and we contract it to mu of g
over epsilon
vertices we can assume that we know mu
of g because we can guess it within one
plus epsilon uh accuracy with running
log n over epsilon parallel copies of
the algorithm
and once we did this kind of contraction
um
any edge of an arbitrary maximum
matching will survive this contraction
step with very high probability with
about one minus for the epsilon vector
so we are not losing much of the
matching through the vertex contractions
and we can work on this friendly size
graph from now
now
there's a slight issue with this
existing approach is that after this
vertex contractions have happened at
initialization some updates might come
which
are dependent on which vertices we have
chosen to contract and ruin the maximum
matching in a contracted
graph while
might not ruin the maximum matching in
the original graph so this aptitude
doesn't work against so-called adaptive
updates where the adversary who's
completing the updates is aware of the
random bits of the algorithm has chosen
so
we solve this problem
through
running this with a contraction step
a number of times in parallel
and what it did what we are going for
here is that we want to guarantee that
regardless how these contractions
happened
and what edges are deleted from the
original graph in one of the contracted
sub graph a maximum any maximum matching
or most of any maximum matching will
still exist
what we find is that if we take a small
number of completely random vertex
contractions
uh
small by small i mean polylog number of
parallel vertex contractions then we are
already happy because in one of them
with high probability we will have a
well preserved maximum matching but and
this is essentially
robust against an adaptive adversary
since the randomization happens at the
start of the algorithm and works with
high probability on any kind of input
which comes afterwards um on the other
hand this is inherently uh
randomized and we would like it to be
deterministic for the sort of state of
completeness and we show how to do this
through basing the contractions
on the edge sets of specific
expander graphs
however
the existing algorithms for designing
such expander graphs will require us to
introduce an ant to the little of one
overhead and that's why we get this
o hat of one
blew up
unfortunately okay so these are the core
ideas of the paper the small many
smaller steps
building up a framework and these small
steps separately
uh
makes sense
they're very independently presented
and this results in a number of possible
research directions at least i hope
so the edcs
concept or matching specifier was very
influential and it has found a number of
applications it has fun applications in
different settings such as streaming as
well not just dynamic and static
and
this version of it which is sort of
locally damaged and therefore is easier
to be found might have some applications
the framework we present here
only uses the fact that we are working
with a matching problem
uh in on the only way it uses the fact
that we're working on a metric from
problem is that
we assume that we can find a solution in
the union of the small number of output
days which is true for the matching
problem but it is true for other
problems as well which means that it
might have applications outside of the
matching problem
and
i also think that this sort of new
method of vertex construction which is
works against adaptive adversaries or
even
in the randomized setting might have
applications for the matching problem in
different settings
because it allows us to
deterministically assume that the
matching size in the graph is pretty
much the same
as the size of the graph itself within
some slight parameters
thank you for listening